[Music]
these fast becoming famous backbenchers
back on stage with results helping to
determine the emerging front runners in
this leadership race
mordent 67
sunak 88 the voting played out in these
rooms on this very corridor determining
who has a shot at becoming our next pm
this relatively unknown candidate fast
impressing the right honourable penny
mordent mp
our next prime minister
former cabinet minister penny morden to
brexiteer with a backing the british
people are fed up
they're fed up with us not delivering
they're fed up with unfulfilled promises
and they're fed up with divisive
politics
her politics are promised for low taxes
a small state and personal
responsibility but she'll need to sell
herself to the public not just her party
you're the big unknown in this contest
the public have no idea who you are one
diarist describes you as theresa may
with bigger hair
if you win this election will you like
may call another general election to get
your mandate i was a candidate at the
last general election i stood on the
same platform as these good people in
front of me and i think what the public
wants us to do is deliver on that now
another campaign launch done in a race
that is now speeding up and heating up
we'll know who the final two candidates
will be in the coming few days this now
a race as unpredictable as it is bitter
her backers though predicting penny
mordant could go all the way she didn't
engage in the sort of
dutch auction of tax promises she said
we want growth we want to deliver we
want to be competitive in the world and
she knows how she's going to do it the
country wants
uh can they want change
i don't think they want someone from
this cabinet for the last six nine
months they're looking for someone who
can be a change who will replace you
prime minister
who has your vote change certainly come
in however this plays out today the
incumbent boris johnson head into his
penultimate appearance at pmq's shut up
and the mood in this place as fractious
as the tory leadership race anger
attacks and acrimony is the diet around
here these days
if you want to go out go out now the
labour leader looking past the outgoing
prime minister to his possible successor
his attack lines aimed at former
chancellor rishi sanak does he agree
that anyone running to be prime minister
should declare where they and their
families have been domiciled for tax
purposes
and whether they've ever been a
beneficiary of an offshore tax scheme
boris johnson's surrounded by his
cabinet and now contenders to take his
job
still his tone defiant it's perfectly
true that i leave not at a time of my
choosing i'm also proud of the
leadership that i have given i will be
leaving soon
with
my head held high
but his future up in the air as the
focus moves to the search for his
successor and the attacks on the current
front runner not just coming from inside
the chamber but outside too
how are you
tom tugan hat's still in the run-in
making his stand on solid tory ground
defence policy issuing a thinly veiled
attack on rival rishi sonak over his
refusal to commit to higher defense
spending so when we're talking about
defense spending we've got to be
absolutely clear that we will never put
the safety of our country
doubt
because of bean counters or spreadsheets
security always comes before
spreadsheets are you taking a pop shot
today at rishi sonak the front runner uh
in a race that's already really really
divided you're having a little dig at
the person that you most fear what i'm
doing is i'm explaining the consequences
of the words that we use here in this
race
lots of discussions going on in here as
the different camps caught mps ahead of
the next ballot tomorrow beth rigby sky
news westminster